I've called this reintroduction to
trigonometry because you met
trigonometry last year do you remember
having a look at all of the right-angled
triangles in that kind of thing we have
a look a lot at triangles because if you
have a look at the name of the topic but
this isn't a color I will choose Trigon
is just another name for triangle try
mating 3 go on meeting what we get it's
the same kind of thing that is under the
word polygon right which just means many
so this is a three-sided shape a Trigon
just like a hexagon is a six-sided shape
and so on when you see on the tree like
Optometry or geometry or what else has
the tree on it didn't I say geometry say
it again I said I said geometry right
what does it mean what does it mean we
have a system called the metric system
and what does it have to do with it has
to do with how you measure things very
good so this just means measurement so
trigonometry is all about measuring
triangles and the reason we care so much
about triangles is because triangles are
everywhere in nature in the world even
places you wouldn't necessarily expect
which I'm very excited unite Riggin AMA
tree pretty exclusively focuses on just
the triangles but within this topic this
year will show you will start to give
you a sense of how trigonometry right
angry triangles are hiding in all kinds
of unexpected spots so let's remember
and that's why I've called this
reintroduction if you have a triangle
like this
it's right-angled and over here you've
got a an angle and we use Greek letters
a lot because sometimes we've got Greek
letters and we've got English letters
and we run out of English letters so
that's a theta over there in the bottom
left hand corner in this right angle
triangle you can describe each of the
three sides in relation to theta okay
and the easiest one is the hypotenuse
because the hypotenuse is always in the
same spot which one is it
it's a the hypotenuse it's it's this one
it's the longest one it's opposite yeah
I think it's when I heard opposite the
right angle so let's mark any hypotenuse
like so okay but then you have the other
two sides and we're trying to understand
their position because that's actually
what trigonometry is about position in
relation to theta see this one down the
bottom in fact let's do better than this
one down the bottom let's call this
triangle a B C so do you see AC down the
bottom okay it's right beside theta so
we have a technical word for beside we
call it a Jason like so and then lastly
BC is right on the other side we call
this the opposite very good I'm gonna
write it vertically okay
so wonderful now we understand or we use
trigonometric ratios the ratios are
called sine cos and ten the sine is
short for sinusoidal because is short
for you never you never learnt that
right because it's short for cosine and
the tan is short for tangent will come a
little bit later on as to why they are
called what they're called but just like
logs just like logs just like square
roots they attach to a number so you
can't say sine equals something but you
can't say sine of theta you see how sine
is an operation attaches to an angle
just like cos attaches to an angle and
tan attaches to an angle now last year
you learn a mnemonic device a memory
device for remembering which ratios
match with which sides what was the
device sohcahtoa let's I'll write it up
the top you might like to write it like
this
like so some people also you may have
learnt it written like this either these
is fine the second one what it helps you
remember is the order of the ratios so
sine is opposite on hypotenuse cos is
adjacent on hypotenuse and tan is
opposite on adjacent okay so either vote
is fine let's have a look at what it
means in this particular triangle for
this particular angle sine is opposite
on hypotenuse and I went ahead and I
named all of these vertices which means
I've labeled the sides so what's the
name of the opposite side BC and the
hypotenuse is going to be a B Alex good
cause is adjacent on hypotenuse so
therefore I can say it's AC on a B and
then lastly tan is opposite on adjacent
so it's BC on AC okay I want to also
point out at this moment that while we
can think about tan as opposite on
adjacent you can also think about 10
I'll put this in another color blue it
you can also think about tan as sine
theta on cos theta did you notice that
have a look at the top two fractions
there if you did sine theta on cos theta
to see how they both have a B on the
bottom they both have a B on the
denominator so therefore if you divide
one by the other abs would both
disappear they'd cancel each other out
leaving you with BC on AC just like you
saw in the first place okay so this is
all fine but we have a look at the same
triangle there's the right angle in the
bottom right hand corner there's the
theta we were just talking about but
there's another angle up the top so I'm
just gonna call this I'm gonna introduce
your new letter for you I'm gonna call
this guy Phi another Greek letter so
it's just a circle with a line all the
way
through it vertical like excuse me not
to be confused with the deathly hallows
phi is another angle same triangle so
I'll label them then all the points the
same a b and c but remember i mentioned
to you that trigonometry is a lot about
position so therefore if you're thinking
about phi rather than thinking about
theta then the names of the sides kind
of rearrange relative to each other
except for the hypotenuse the hypotenuse
is still the hypotenuse but now the
opposite and adjacent sides are in
different spots because opposite and
adjacent are position dependent words
right what's adjacent to me right now
the whiteboard but that's different to
what's adjacent to you depending on
whatever wherever you are okay so over
here now where's the adjacent side which
one is it you can name it BC is the
adjacent so let's label that and
likewise the opposite side isn't where
it was before the opposite side is AC so
let me say that again what percent and
adjacent our position words and their
relative to where you're thinking about
okay I often like to think about you
know you're a guy and you're standing up
here and you're you're looking at this
triangle from this position and for some
reason you have a line right through
your face and from there what's next to
you it's this side what's opposite you
it's this side so let's write for this
particular angle sine Phi cos Phi and
1005
okay one at a time sine opposite on
hypotenuse AEC on maybe okay cos Phi
will be BC on a B and then lastly yeah
AC on BC okay so
not too complicated an idea and of
course we could change all of these into
numbers dependent on how big or small
our triangle is okay